right goodnight everybody welcome
tonight's busy planning be my name is
Andy Crump I will be chairing junkie
bring it round rather than throw it
please my name is Andy crumple will
return tonight's meeting where we saw I
done the planning merit of the
applications before us before we start
please could everybody make sure their
phones are either switched off or on
silent and I want just check mine as
well officer there's nothing worse than
being interrupted and fall fly with the
tunes of the great escape or hey big
spender and can I also crave your
indulgence on not to interrupt the
speakers only people who are registered
to speak are there to speak tonight it
might be very tempting but unfortunately
it's not allowed so like to introduce
the top table Thank You chairman Lester
balls for committee services thanks nice
legal services Louise cool Moon Senior
Planner
and I'm Richard Gardner on the Planning
Manager for tonight's meeting and just
to touch on what my role is that's to
provide impartial advice to clarify any
planning issues that arise and to assist
members decision taking I'm bound by the
Royal Town Planning Institute's code of
Professional Conduct and importantly
planning committee members are not bound
by advice and officers or by their
recommendations thank you thank you
Richard Wright first on the agenda
apologies for absence thank you this
item number two disclosures of interest
yes first but following reputation speak
with a ward member thank you care to
join it yep thank you any of this no
thank you
right item number three the minutes I'm
happy that's all I sign and confirm the
minutes of the meeting how old on the
5th of February thank you right we'll
now move on to the first item on the
agenda which is application number 19
slash zero one six zero one a few our
Lund off reg credit rate studly material
change of use from vacant agricultural
run into residential color on site for
two bleaches for occupation by gypsy
Taylor family with associated heart
standing package treatment plant utility
brach store sheds and DA bronze heart
rip splitting and percent an officer is
Louise
Thank You chair and the application site
is identified by the black dot on the
map and is located to the north of
studly town the application site is
identified by the site edged in red and
is located in the West Midlands
Greenbelt and also in the Arden special
landscape area and situated
approximately 500 meters north of studly
built Perry boundary the site lies also
within part of a local wildlife site
which includes the larger agricultural
field in which the site is positioned
within in essence the local wildlife
sites incorporates this area here around
to hear this larger field the the site
is also located within 200 meters west
of a are east of a public footpath which
is shown by the dotted green line here
and is located on the other side of that
field in which it's situated within the
Green Line there also just for your
reference there is for a group to eat
preservation order with an area of
woodland retrospective planning
permission is sought for material change
of use of the land into a caravan site
for two households
mr. and mrs. leverage and their three
younger children which comprise one
household and their eldest son and his
wife as the second household the
building sorry the site is proposed to
comprise of two pictures with space for
a static caravan and utility building
and space for parking for two vehicles
within each pitch also for touring
caravans and a storage building as
proposed on site the applicant has
identified a need for two Tory caravans
to provide accommodation for their
son and daughter who are of an age
required to - sorry of an age to require
separate bedroom accommodation and the
other - touring caravans are opposed to
use for travelling purposes for each
home household adapt dog kennels is
proposed within the amenity land to the
west of the site within here just
outside this area of hard standing
whilst not shown on the plan six low
level external lights have been erected
within the site and like the lights have
been positioned on the fencing which has
been erected within the site itself and
set approximately 2 meters off the
ground so the positions of the lights
are here here here here and then by the
main entrance along approximately these
positions here but facing into the site
the site is accessed off the reddit's
road and following comments from the
highway authority the access gates has
been amended to incorporate a separate
pedestrian access also to enable it to
achieve a 5 meter width turning to the
actual plans of the structures so this
is the proposed timber sheds
these haven't been erected to date also
this is the dog kennels which is
proposed so with five runs these are the
domestic dogs for the the owners and
this is the post and that is the sorry
it's a there's a storage building the
these are apologies it's utility
buildings sorry about that so this is
turning now to the photographs of the
site this is the site access has a
currently Institute you can see the
existing road frontage this is the
reddit road and these tree planting a
mature tree planting in present
this is the pedestrian access which is
recently being provided this is within
the site now so I'm looking towards the
site that serve an boundary so this is
the storage building which is in place
the main static home for one household
this is the other static home now this
is a slightly different orientation to
what is being proposed and is the
applicants have provided assurance that
their meaning to re-orientate that so
this would be an open view when viewed
from the Western public footpath this is
the southern boundary and this is the
one of the lights that have been erected
this is the southwestern corner of the
site so the public footpath is within
this vicinity here but behind the hedge
the intention is from the applicant is
to continue the fencing along here then
retain post and rail fencing along the
western boundary these are some of the
dog kennels which are currently on site
prior to the construction of they
proposed dog kennels and this is looking
towards the northern boundary this is
the western boundary as well so this is
northern this is the Western and the
post and rail fencing proposed to
continue along this area with the
amenity space here and then this is
looking towards a northern boundary here
you can see some of the domestic
caravans which are used in association
with the properties on Green Lane not
associated with this site and then this
is looking towards the eastern boundary
here so the road frontage you can see
the existing mature trees is proposed to
continue this fencing along this
boundary here and then with the post of
rail fencing here with one of the
touring caravans so this is the
visibility's place
this is looking towards studly and this
is the northern visibility display and
then this is just looking at directly
opposite where there's a small
industrial unit and domestic property
now this is taken from the public
footpath which is 200 meters to the west
of the site so it is the I am to be fair
looking in and obviously this is in
winter looking through the existing
hedgerow so you can see just about the
this the site here and then I have step
back so you can see the existing
vegetation along that that boundary here
so this is a footpath route is
effectively along here and this is not
well this is an existing field access in
order to get to the wider area of land
agricultural land adjoining the new site
but I thought was helpful for members
although it's not effectively a public
vantage point so you wouldn't
necessarily know it's down there it just
just provide context of the existing
southern boundary the sorry in summary
in the assessment of this sorry in the
assessment of this proposed development
impact on the Greenbelt impact on the
Greenbelt it's clear that this is deemed
to be inappropriate development
whereupon very special circumstances to
require to be demonstrated to outweigh
this harm and the very special
circumstances provided are materially
relevant in this assessment and when one
considers the recently endorsed GTA a
2009 report that's a gypsy and travel
accommodation assessment
that identifies the need for up to 70
additional pictures up to 2035 in
combination with the personal
circumstances of the applicant and also
the lack of alternative site provision
it's considered that there is clear and
demonstratable very circuit very special
circumstances that outweigh the harm
that justifies granting of a planning
permission for a temporary period as a
recommended in the report Thank You
chair Louise there's no updates on this
one no thank you okay can we move on to
our first speaker which is catch the
demon from snuggly hello
three minutes as per the usual form and
do you want a warning with about 30
seconds to go thank you
members of the planning committee thank
you for the opportunity to speak at
tonight's meeting study parish council
is extremely concerned that officers
have recommended this application for
approval to emphasize how concerned we
are as many cancer's as we are able have
come along tonight to see this
application refused in recent years 30
residents have felt that as SDC has
ignored their wishes this is your
opportunity to show that study does
matter and the SDC does listen we trust
you've all read the documents and the
comments submitted by residents against
this application their reasons are many
and varied and are supported by the
numerous complaints the SDC
enforcement team have dealt with those
reasons in themselves our reason for
refusal we are basing our objection
perlier on policy the MPP F gives clear
guidance that all development in the
Greenbelt should be resisted unless a
very special circumstances exist
officers have tried to use a variety of
reasons to justify this application
including not having the five-year land
supply and have now gone for temporary
permission rather than permanent which
was applied for in their opinion and in
the policy as this council has adopted
this application is an inappropriate
development officers also chose not to
inform the adjacent Authority something
the leader of Redditch Borough Council
was not pleased about these societies
within 50 meters of redditch residents
and is already at a negative impact on
the value of homes that are bought this
side in our parish plan adopted in 2017
95 percent of residents felt we green
spaces are key component to life in the
village on our key to maintain separate
segregation between thirdly unread itch
to protect the Greenbelt that presents
prevents coalescence core strategy
insects from 6 8 13 clearly identifies
this is an area
as a location where development is
inappropriate and development should be
resisted to event Redditch encroaching
on sturdily policy a sha-1 also
identifies that the separation already
is important to maintain status identity
public policy cs5 and cs9 would also be
breached is it this application does not
protect the surrounding open inverted
character of the landscape and does not
integrate with the surrounding setting
policy CS 21 which deals with [ __ ] in
travel sites states proposals for the
provision of permanent temporary transit
sites will be considered against the
following criteria section 1 we do not
believe that this is important to use
the childís justification is clutching
at straws
if settled education was that important
why move from where you were just
somewhere you know is illegal and you
will be moved on where is the evidence
of a child attending a school section to
this site will not compromise was
rejected only national or local
designation it is a special landscape
area and it does compromise it the other
one section 11 will not have an
unacceptable adverse impact on
neighborhood residential mmunity it does
surveyman came to a very close point
there so yeah thank you very much right
mr. Beaman questions for the parish
cancer cancer Mills thanks for sharing
with any consultation with the with the
Parish Council on this at all okay so
this is a site that the applicant turned
up on a Friday bank holiday weekend
drove a digger straight through what was
an existing fence and proceeded to put
two loads of lorry loads in there no
I'll take that the answer is there
wasn't any one of them yes you spoke you
spoke their enforcement what we has no
enforcement team being down there since
the unfortunate cancel
okay I thought any other questions I can
Thank You mr. chairman just on a
clarification because you were talking
about the division between subtly and
and Redditch could you could you let me
know the meadow cottages are they
actually in Redditch oh and incidentally
meadow cottages that are to the
immediately to the north of the site are
instantly the red line denotes the
boundary of redditch so everything the
other side of that is in red edge
actually isn't a total division between
radiation stuck in in that particular
instance one question before mr. Damon
but the site access to your jobs on the
site axis this has been comments about
it being next to a dangerous and busy
junction have you got any evidence of
any accidents or near that junction I
think the the the main concern that we
have hit here because the worst I feel
gate there beforehand is that with the
vehicles come in a with Tarun caravans
it's a very slow exit and that is a
national speed limit section there so
you can't cut upon that very quickly and
it is it doesn't really give you time to
get it with the car
and yeah like yes is a very valid point
did you indicate cancer folding know if
you dig no no kiddo no further questions
thank you very much right move on to our
next speaker which is the ward member
gets the hand you're serving
have you got five minutes Peter okay
Thank You chef
first of all I'd like to make a
withdrawal of a reference to making
access into Green Line which is yep
ready okay thank you
[ __ ] side policy CS 21 page one one
eight green belt n PPF core strategy C 5
CS 21 travelers probably an airy
strategy policy I 5 rotate clearly
states that an objection is to retain a
separate and distinctive identity of
studly and maintain the open gap between
ready as member of this committee
Sahra we're supporting this statement
outlined in the NPP F are the first are
the five purpose is of green belt one of
which is to prevent settlement from
merging into one another the Planning
Council consultant acting on behalf of
the applicant describes the proposal as
a development an accurate description
this proposed development is in green
belt less than 50 yards from drain line
ready to diminishing
the presentation of the setting the
cottages that are on green line are long
needle workers cottages and therefore
before the Greenbelt was even thought
about and our historical and social
value not an argument for development
allowing the development here not only
impinges on the integrity of the
Greenbelt but on Stratford on Ivan
district making it look as though it has
merged with reddish causing harm to the
Greenbelt the policy of this planning
authority is to protect the Greenbelt
the applicant moved on to this green
belt land in June 2019 and started to
develop the land to meet their needs
with the out seeking planning permission
a duty required to everybody in the UK
policy C s 21 states clearly that the
provision of temporary or permanent
transit sites have to be considered
against criteria this site is not
located in the Greenbelt the
arrangements are put into place to
ensure proper management of the site to
seek to ensure community cohesion
between settled and traveler communities
councillors are aware receiving
complaints of noise pollution
demonstrated by barking dogs and other
complaints you have had occupying the
site with a Planning Commission does not
suggest community cohesion is a priority
the National Planning policy framework
requires the council so identify sites
to meet accommodation needs for all
communities in the area policy CS 21 in
our adopted core strategy sets a general
criteria against which proposals to be
considered the council is developing
gypsy in troubled local plant a gypsy
traveller local plan will provide
further guidance to identify sites work
being on this guidance in 2014 and many
of the steps and processes involved have
been completed
therefore the council must be close to
publishing the sites that have been
identified
[Applause]
it would seem sensible to wait to see
which sites are identified rather than
applicants tell us where sites should be
when over several years the council has
put considerable work into this issue
for the reasons or give are with us the
committee not to grant planning
permission on any basis cattle don't go
Peter Peter under 6 21 it comments about
the development and use of the site
makes best use of previously developed
untidy or derelict land
what was this land used for prior to the
start of development
this is previous to the travellers maybe
not it was basically a failed but it's
the failed up next to it is obviously
agricultural use so I don't know exactly
what they use that was just that I feel
burned the cottages small section was it
in its grass field but happiness
I mean did it have life stalking it did
it have sheep did it have it was it
ability lands of abandoned can I just
can I just ask a farmer who farms next
to that because I'm not sure the full
answer that on this occasion yes yes are
you aware of any listed buildings
you mentioned the cottages off Green
Lane listed are they aware of them being
listed properties well they are all
needle makers cottages I don't know if
they list it or not mushroom okay
application office
okay so failed him put microphone on
please John John John it's going off
again thank you
the indications about the can we go back
on to the site plan sorry where you've
got the septic tank or tank of some sort
the indications were that he'd overflows
regularly is that the case accordance of
the neighbors there there is an overflow
now going into some Gardens which has
never happened before trying to do a bit
only awaken I'm just trying to see where
you're going with this question yes yes
it's probably more appropriate for the
officers about the impact them and
whether environmental health mean cause
rather than I think it's a bit unfair on
the ward member to to know that one
question on that but are you happy that
we asked that question to the water and
to the offices well there is a concern
that where is the drainage but your ward
member may I mean the council right any
further questions
you're afraid to go on this occasion
thank you right moving swiftly on to
pause a clarification I believe kinds of
the feeling you've got one on that
drainage drainage and Stroke sewerage
that there doesn't seem to be a
an area where they can get in there to
pump it out and this is what was
concerning me which sewage does need to
be done regularly through Utah and the
access for any effectively with the
waste disposal vehicle to enter into the
site world would go via reddit road as
as it is occurring at present and prior
to that that this site had a portaloo
which was being just emptied that's the
correct word emptied I think on a couple
of week basis the cost of that was such
as prohibitively expensive
they've then obviously invested and put
the package treatment plant but
ultimately if planning permission was
granted the applicant is now indicated
that they would be actually connecting
to the main sewer because so they've got
agreement in principle from seven Trent
in order to do so and the cost of which
would be it wouldn't be prohibited yes
page 15 John section five water and long
until addressed
yep considerate I just wondered whether
you could clarify the council has a duty
under the Housing Act 2004 which is
quite clearly stated in here to produce
assessments of current and future
accommodation and you say that that
there is there was an update done in in
June 2019 but there still is not
withstanding a five-year it the council
cannot and has not been able to
demonstrate the five-year supply either
existing or new that is considered to be
quite a considerable special risk the
special I just wondered whether you can
cough I whether and is there any
likelihood given recent discussions in
cabinet and other I think whether there
is in any likelihood in the immediate
future that that five-year supply is
likely to be met through you we can't
comment development management offices
on the likelihood of that happening that
would be something for your policy
officers to advise on we've been
cognizant of that in recommending in the
way we have to give time for the council
to produce the [ __ ] in traveler
strategy and in that regard that's
what's recommended with a three-year
temporary permission to allow time for
that to take place
how long that will take I can't say but
the three-year temporary condition would
allow this site to then be reviewed at
that point in time to see one of the
council's at a point where the strategy
has been brought forward and
alternatives are available to gypsies
and travellers but just just to recap
we've actually in a position in 2019 not
able to respond to a Housing Act of 2004
that's correct yes
it's just concerns me if we're going to
be working on the three-year period and
yet where we're looking for them to
landscape submit the revised planting
hedgerows and other matters surely that
is a more of a long-term issue than it
is to five years are you saying that you
don't think it's achievable within the
three years I don't think whatever they
plant is going to be of any size within
three years to be technically a boundary
or whatever they want you to plant it
fall over need a question yeah I think
it's the fielding was sent one is it
appropriate to have this type of
landscaping and joined that for a
three-year period temporary period and
will it be sufficient screening will it
grow enough time in the three years I
think that was it's it's crazy that
we're giving them three years to do it
in an icon John I've asked the question
so I think we're gone Richard yeah
you're absolutely right if the
landscaping goes in now it will take
time to establish but that's the same
for any development that you seek to
screen in this circumstance yeah there
would be a period of time where it went
on the screen but after three years
there would be some level of screening
but at that point it would be necessary
to review where we are hence the
recommendation I've got a question again
just to make sure we're clear that after
the three years and we've had there's a
council sufficient sites locations a
number of plots sites which is whatever
the words you want to use available to
meet our five year supply at the end of
this three years if we'd got those
numbers we could then say the Commission
is ended and we would see the trouble is
to move elsewhere JYP's isn't roasted
meat from the valves there if you were
to grant permission with the three-year
condition then that would end in any
event and it would be necessary to renew
the permission with the further
application
it's impossible to say what the planning
balance would be of any future
application in three years time but if
the council was at a point where it had
identified sites elsewhere then that
balance would undoubtedly change but by
how much we don't know because there's
other circumstances in that balance but
it would change bring not swirls trying
to get doing the roundabout by but thank
you for interpreting we're trying to say
it Arijit catch the mouse
thanks mr. chairman I'm just looking on
page 9 on the on the letter of objection
mr. just for the officer it says one of
one of the comments in sight is located
outside their built-up area boundary of
Stanley and is it's in open countryside
location contrary to the core strategy
is that correct yes it is correct it's
outside the built-up area boundaries to
and contrary to the course factually
country's core strategy in that regard
so in this regard then it is and in that
regard yeah and that runs parallel will
the Greenbelt point hence the need for
very special circumstances and way that
and it is on Greenbelt it is on
Greenbelt yes thank you
right and you further questions
generators they're electrical generators
which is of course is that disturbance
to the locality what control have we got
over sound and noise
environmental health officers have
assessed this and it concluded they have
no objection and therefore that any
environmental impact terms of noise is
acceptable and that they would have had
regard to the arrangements put forward
you have been told that they are
currently on mains electricity so that
would have been part of the
environmental health officers
considerations Council Fleming and then
I see Environmental Health have made an
inspection on there in relation to the
dog kennels but if I I know the area
well please going to school instantly so
remembers reasonably good and there are
people in Green Lane are close and
there's also a rubber Terrace cottages
on that triangular piece used to be the
Griffon public is Roma terrace houses
there now and even on the distance that
there is having lived close to a place
where there's half a dozen dogs in
kennels then further away than those are
I know that can be a problem but
environmental health have said that they
don't see that as an issue I'm
struggling with that you know but that's
that's just a personal point of view
yeah can tonight we've seen two gone
when the house is a few times if it can
be caught clear when we're asking
questions point for clarifications and
con against trying to stick what we've
got in front of us as well
lots of position what if at the moment
so if we can try and stick to what we've
got in front of us and again can we make
it's not statements questions and again
I think the point is we look at what
we've got in front of us what the
evidence is and we're winding that up
and the points of clarification and not
for making statements so can we get to
the point as quickly as possible
otherwise we're going to hear it or not
thank you thank you in terms of the
provision of site provision across the
district where are we in terms of the
number of sites that we are currently
able as an authority what have we been
able to provide to date if you go to the
foot of page 16 it gives you an update
on where we are with the GTA 8th which
is adding travel availability assessment
and in total we'd need as a district to
provide 70 before 2035 so that's what
we're short by 59 again 749 that we're
obliged to provide an 11 that were
potentially required to provides at 17
total so we are currently providing not
very many we're providing obviously that
there's various dips and travel sites
around the district but that's what the
shortfall is so I wouldn't want you to
think we don't have any we do we have a
fair deal but when we look at what we
need to provide because of that GTAA
update we're seventy short and if we
look at the map on CS
21 well the board locations are
identified in color from the did for my
screen through stuff you've got two
major areas and I think they're
described as the Haven Valley and
somewhere else when it's described as a
valley remainder of the district outside
the console a and B are the majority of
sites in that area or are they outside
that area do we have a focus or not I
couldn't say where we are with the
detail of the GTAA going forward that
that's a policy matter but ultimately I
can say that but none of them are in the
Greenbelt so they'll be away from that
because that's what that policy stays it
towards that is ongoing work at the
moment so if we then move on the reason
that we that you're proposing this is
acceptable if you go through all the
exceptions in in CS 21 is purely on the
very special circumstances which seem to
relate about the need to access a
doctor's surgery and the fact that we
haven't provided enough one of the gtao
yes in brief officers considered that
it's been demonstrated there's three
specific very special circumstances
firstly the lack of the supply of sites
secondly the lack of alternative sites
and thirdly the personal circumstances
of the applicant yes
those special circumstances there's no
reason why a site couldn't be provided
within the two bands to set up the co 21
being the Avon Valley and the other
parts of the district rather than
absolutely not it could be but at the
moment it hasn't been but okay we've
discussed that quite well right you move
on to the results for more on conditions
go on there 101 conditions is that there
should be no bonfires there was a very
significant bonfire taking place today
when I visited the site which is
slightly concerning but the chemically
conditioned that the far water is
connected to the main saw in response
your first question should be no
bonfires condition 11 says there should
be no burning waste at the site that
would cover that notwithstanding
obviously what you saw say so and what
was can it be condition that the site is
linked into the mains foul water system
[Music]
fifteen sometime degrees in order to
connect to the line service phase 15
section five it's acceptable to have a
septic tank so therefore that means that
if you wish to condition something else
it would be unnecessary because the
existing solution is acceptable because
as of the 1st of January 2020 the use of
a septic tank without considerable in
hoffman is no longer legal and therefore
you have to have a private sewage works
for one for better word as of 1/1 2020
and therefore using a septic tank as far
as I understand from the environmental
legislation it's no longer an acceptable
method of I just come in on this one
obviously page 15 whether I said the
applicants have put forward that is
intention to connect to the main side
should plan information be forthcoming
like a timed agreement from 7/10 in
order to connect to the main sewer which
is located within the verge of the area
journey on their side so again my BMI is
that a reasonable condition and its life
if they've agreed to anyway I'm not
aware of that the acne referred to that
the condition would duplicate that act
if that act requires people to do it in
a certain way then 7th with other powers
to enforce that act and all the
condition do would do the duplicate it
and again it would death will be
unnecessary
can we just go back over to that the
applicant has indicated in the report
that they were wanting to attach to the
the main sewer and they've ordered that
attained agreement with seventh rent if
I'm reading page could we put a
condition so it's an unreasonable
conditions not in the control of the fee
so could we put a note on the
application same committee catch the
mouse
Jim are you now allowed to run a
business from from this site you could
so we're not when I look through it
extremely busy you know lots of yeah
edition number nine no commercial
activities no promotion Society included
in order to tell you look really really
busy when a lot okay so no commercial
thank you cancel kettle you were saying
if you found the the app to you
mentioned to do with septic tanks
just looking at the moment I found a
reference to it numerals from juice in
2015 which means property and it'll be
required to upgrade their systems Devon
already on the server the next two years
basically replacing septic tanks with
small sewage treatment plants for
domestic use hence a septic tank
my understanding is no longer an
acceptable solution and therefore it
must be and I that what I'm saying is
can we condition that they've come to an
agreement with center and it doesn't
necessarily require them to do so what I
was suggesting is that we do require
them as a condition to connect into the
main network if we were to grab the
mission
come back put sound up my somewhat a
legal officer is saying that we might be
able to put the condition in but if I
can't come to some agreement with seven
Trent that condition won't be
enforceable won't be practicable well
under environmental permitting England
and Wales amendment of England
regulation 2014 which came into force on
Thursday January created general binding
rules GB ours and the GB are saying
anybody with a septic tank discharging
to us-ward course must replace it or
upgrade it by the 1st of January 2020 or
sooner the property sold for this date
or what the Environment Agency finds
that it's causing pollution that
indicates the septic tank is not an
acceptable solution for dealing with
waste on their site after the first of
what foot 1 1 20 therefore there must be
a better solution and therefore they're
not connecting in to the septic into the
farm water system they must have a
compliance system obviously is an issue
that we need to discuss I think we might
have a deferral i deferment of the
meeting because she raised something
that's not in the report but is is
significant and will make an impact on
this and we need to make sure whatever
conditions we put in a enforceable
reasonable etcetera so I'm proposing I
improve the German whilst we look at
that particular issue so if you're happy
to agree that all those in favor
[Music]
right sorry about that when we need to
make sure what was being proposed was
reasonable a reasonable and necessary
condition and stood on Thank You
chairman all conditions have to make six
tests under the MPF and one of those
tests is that they are necessary
councillor Kevin you've mentioned some
new legislation around the use of
packaged treatment plants and that kind
of thing that will be controlled by
seventh rent or possibly by the
Environment Agency in terms of pollution
both of those authorities are powers of
the different acts from the Planning Act
and for that reason any condition that
sought to control the the failed
drainage of the site would be
unnecessary and therefore wouldn't make
the test so the advice I gave previously
stands for those reasons we'll move on
so we've gone through lots of
clarification so I think we spent time
we went on to the debate so who wants to
start on this one case the fielding
the comments made by this debate or
clarification stop its debate thank you
is that I never get clarified about
anything the the fact that this water
this thing is overflowing and as we
understand it at the moment and the
indications are that the neighbors are
having far water going into the drains
or the ditches by their gardens we've
got to get something that is a much
better system than they're using at the
moment and from the indications are
about getting onto the mains it sounds a
very difficult thing that we're gonna
have to deal with so my feelings are
very much that there are a lot of
unknowns on this site particularly being
in the green belt and but that side of
it that I'm proposing to refuse it
reasons cascara the we have to consider
this on on purely planning grounds and
they're very special circumstances and
this that the the debate is about in
planning the position and they contend
of the conditions around the green belt
and national pine policy framework but
on the other side is the fact that this
council has not in many years fulfilled
its responsibilities on providing gypsy
and traveler sites and that is a
District Council and County Council
responsibility and we've not done it and
that is that is why it's considered such
a very special circumstance how's the
cattle in part I agree with counselors
unit that we do not have a five year
supply of trouble sites as I high-level
all in fact they planning members are
highlighted earlier on so we do have
that as a key issue to take into account
but I'm not sure whether our failure to
deliver in the district overrides the
cs20 one which I thought was written
when we still did not have a gypsy
traveller supply lost the actual so
let's go back to the application
what we have is under CS 21 a specific
requirement that it should direction
travel sites should not be in the
Greenbelt area and we've got a
significant proportion illiterate which
is not Greenbelt
so the balance is what are the special
circumstances and I don't believe that
not providing sufficient sites allows
that it to be special to this site I
think it will revolves more about the
medical needs of the child which need to
be met by a doctor surgery and the child
we understand is actually getting that
support from one in Studley so it is
that issue as far as I'm concerned
whether that bail overrides see s21
which is very clear the site is should
this year's 21 the very first point the
site is not located within the Greenbelt
unless there are very special
circumstances and that fact we haven't
delivered not sight so do not think it's
a special circumstance so what we
haven't explored is whether the special
special needs and it's normal sentences
and appropriate description but I'm
going to use the words anyway and now
with the special needs of this child
could be met only in snuggly or whether
they could be met by any doctor surgery
in the district and that is something
regrettably I didn't prefer but earlier
on during points of clarification so I
don't know whether officers might be
able to weather the channel we allow me
to ask for that detail because I think
that is the critical issue if the means
can be met anywhere in the district then
we have a policy which outlines where it
is acceptable and that is not within the
green belt under the sea s21 does have a
clear map while we should leave the site
should be
right I think just before we move on
I've been buyers and I agree how hard
that if we are going to discuss the
medical condition to need that the
individual involved in this case we're
going to have to go into a private
session which means I'm right I'm going
to have to clear the room so I think I
think it's pertinent is this sorry about
another adjournment because we have to
have a specific ruling that I have to
read that to for our legal obligations
but I think is is very pertinent we have
to make sure people's privacy is
protected so again I know it's
unsatisfactory we've been here a long
while we've been going over an hour but
we do need to get this right so
apologies for that
need to invoke the actual schedule of
the Local Government Act I think what
the reports are showing is that council
council actually address the points that
the medical needs is a major
consideration and we do need to discuss
that but we do need to go in private now
you'll say we didn't need to go into
into a private meeting so chair if we
could just invoke section 100 a brackets
for scheduled trial by and that's refers
to access to a private individual and if
we go back if we could invoke that
section and they'll be go to private
publication happy to endorse the section
just mentioned by the officer and we go
to a private session thank you thank you
right
cancer Fionan you've got your proposal
oh sorry yes I will draw my question oh
my proposal the word following sorry
chair it was a proposal to refuse cancer
fielding so what are you drawing that
thank you catskil frightened I'm I'm
gonna make a proposal given that the
very special circumstances includes
reference to three items one of which I
think we require for a plan for further
clarification on I'm suggesting that we
request officers to obtain further
clarification on will those items and
therefore this applications to third
from this meeting second what sorry
somebody's was playing the great this
application is deferred to another the
subsequent planning meeting giving
officers the time to obtain that further
third party information information and
when they've received that it's brought
back to planning committee from they
belong to be better informed about the
very special circumstances argument has
been put forward well that's my proposal
can we get the applicant to stop work on
the development there that's a separate
matter for enforcement therefore
regulator committee Claire just need a
second of that sorry before
sorry chair before I just confirm the
councillor kettles proposal just to be
clear because this discussion went into
quite it comes and Dean's failed thank
you must be trying to thought we went to
close session basically we went there
because of the medical records issues so
basically that's what we will be seeking
issues on so it was just to clarify that
point because we need to come up with a
proper reason as well they're going to
suggest deferment the reason is the
argument to grant the application are
the very special circumstances and we
need to make sure they're very special
circumstances of evidence and
clarification of what they are and at
the moment there's still some ambiguity
about that so we need to have that
clarity clarification before we make any
decision so we can make reasonable
decisions so we've had a proposal from
Castle kettle to defer this application
and seconded by Councillor fielding all
those in favor a deferral this
application for further information
committee was to defer this application
thank you on the break and we will
before we move on to the next item will
have a five-minute break
the West can get what move on to our
second item which is application 1902 7
7 0 ful Gary Locke sand Ulster
demolition of 30 lock-up garages and
constructing the five dwellings and
associated works and now presented
officer Thank You German the application
before members is for the demolition of
30 lockup garages just off the Luna
Avenue and the erection of five
dwellings this slide shows the site
edged in red with the pink line denoting
the boundary between the parishes and
wards of Ulster which societies within
and Kinison adjacent this aerial image
shows the right side edge in red within
the wider context of Ulster
demonstrating that is within the Bab and
close to town services this image says a
shout for the site in more detail
this is the proposed site layout as you
can see the five dwellings would be
arranged in a set of three dwellings and
one pair with parking and landscaping to
the front and gardeners to the rear here
are the proposed elevations and floor
plans this photo shows the entrance from
Malina Avenue the plan in the right hand
corner shows where I'm standing to take
the photo
these next photos are from within the
site
here is a photo taken from street view
which gives an idea of the character of
the street scene to conclude the
principle of development is established
by virtue of the sustainable location
within austere the design is considered
to be in keeping with the character of
the area County highways have raised no
objection to the access arrangement and
so the recommendation to members is to
grant the application subject to the
conditions within the report thanks our
first speaker which is cancer mark cargo
from Boston castle Thank You Jerry three
minutes far away when you're ready
members also Town Council have serious
reservations about this application
first we can accept the principle
development on this site but not over
development this is a poor quality
design with five homes being squeezed
into a small plot there's insufficient
parking the applicants have provided the
absolute minimum but no visitor spaces
they stake that does not matter as there
are sufficient of spaces parking spaces
in the environs we have previously
enforced the principle that each
development should provide its own
parking spaces required austere Town
Council Astro tracking plan to
demonstrate that in fact vehicles could
use the aperture provider spaces which
which were not convinced I had not seen
that
finally on offsite parking the adjoining
road is only five meters wide and
designed for 1950s traffic not the
larger vehicles of today we constantly
see vehicles parked on the verges all
Town Council had asked a sprinklers to
be provided due to the distance away
from the road for emergence vehicle
access this has been provided on similar
sites in the same location or locale not
this one or not the site isn't an
elevated position and therefore will
overlook adjacent properties there is
insufficient bin storage only at the
point that in the report permission will
be sought to provide bin storage in
compliance
ow who from what if this is not achieved
more disruption the gardens of the
absolute minimum are stated in the
report there is no front garden this is
poor amenity for our residents I do not
see any alternate energy provisions such
as solar or ground our source heating
and that does not shine without the
climate emergency this council recently
moved my main reason for refusal reason
for asking for refusal is a poor and
let's be honest about it boring design
of the properties is it just not
acceptable I can already hear the
justification that it respects the
vernacular of the area and other excuses
to come up with poor design a quote from
our core strategy cs9 design and
distinctiveness which states all forms
of development will improve the quality
of the public realm and enhance the
sense of place
he continues high quality design will be
achieved by ensuring that all
development is attractive and of high
architectural quality design remember we
only see the outside of buildings
members the Conway state is one of the
most deprived areas in our district and
deserves more much more the previous
design for some reason superseded
although still over development and the
lack of parking at least included some
architectural features of narrative
thirty-seconds members are nameplate
leaked recently concerned that was
started said two-tier approach to by
developers to what an acceptable quality
of design I cannot for example see a
design of this nature being tolerated in
other parts and districts a fitting turn
so why here this committee has refused
permission for development in the past
based on the quality of design I chaired
that meeting that why not this one
members I asked this application is
refused and let's hope for a better more
acceptable scheme being brought forward
thank you or just over a little bit over
but I gave you some leeway okay
catch something else thank you
you mention about the lot about their
design but the the biddin stores will be
a bit has been storage when the you know
of bin day comes where would they be put
you put your mic on please camera which
by the where the access reaches the road
you'll notice two little blips sticking
out of the red line that is the proposed
area where they're going to put the bins
but there is no they don't have an
permission for that no they didn't have
permission for that the other thing is
that the bins the bin men won't go that
far up into the actual estate so they
have to be closer to the road have they
got permission to put these bins there
not according to the report so what I
can ask the pilot
I'll get clarification or points of
clarification yeah Thank You counselor
Kelso Cargill are you accepting that
this site is suitable for development
but it is P which is the design and
layout that is causing the problem it's
the overdevelopment that causes the
problem yes we're quite we've accepted
three sites now in Austin on the same
estate the old communist agents which I
which are the old orbit garages which
were which have been sold as we were all
aware as through a cross of district and
we accepted three of those already I'd
made a comment and yes we've accepted
those as in principle yes we're happy we
see a little bit development to this
site any further questions
catch the car call you're free to go
thank you very much indeed Channel right
our next speaker is mr. David Jeffries
apologies for keeping you for so long
mr. Jefferies you will have three
minutes would you like a warning with
about 30 seconds to go
thank you very much for this speech
promoters kalsekar but the point across
as a resident of the area the biggest
concern is the fact that is so he's
absolutely packed to the maximum he's
most definitely overdevelopment of the
site I accept that
yeah there is the permission will be
granted but I don't believe that it
should be as heavily I we developed as
it as the proposal suggests there are
issues around obviously the access road
I'll consider it's a small development
because it's five houses are proposed
and there is a lack of pedestrian access
to that site obviously the concern as
well is that the access road is in front
of number 24 and any construction work
that takes place will actually
potentially block the access to their
property there is a drive which isn't
shown on that diagram at the moment and
so it could potentially pose a risk to
the residents because if they need to
leave the house in an emergency by a
vehicle they may not be able to the
there's a concern also about the lack of
parking obviously there's no parking
space without just being overcome by the
point to allowance and the fact that
there is supposedly sufficient parking
in the public area now the photograph of
the junction that was shown earlier is
great but it shows the the total lack of
a part of resident parking there are
vehicles permanently part on the verges
either side of that Junction and
obviously that would then have an impact
on the ability of people passing to and
fro to actually see the traffic it's on
a bend as well which is an issue yeah so
there are no Park vehicles on the verges
but there are always vehicles parked
there various types of the dome
and also at night there is a lot more
cars parked in the public area which is
shown to the left and on the verges
themselves as well so that doesn't
really reflect the actual number of
parked cars that residents have at the
moment given obviously there is no
parking space I'd either there's a
possibility that there will be visitors
then it's gonna the actual availability
of those parking would increase because
it will be done through necessity rather
the choice the fact that they're happy
site itself is elevated above 24 and 26
by probably about two things would
indicate that there's there is a
possibility of overlooking and when the
survey was taken by developers agent
they were not allowed access to the
backyard of number 24 so any I would
expect that any measurement was actually
taken with regards to overlooking may
not necessarily be 100% accurate so that
March to think should be taken into
account as well thank you very much spot
on not so much okay that's Jeff you
state that police sir before there might
be some questions any state nice
building from that image it shows that
there is everly parking down across the
road you can see it's certainly on that
corner there are generally at least two
pole to the right in the picture and
then there are two cars parked to the
left as well you know they're not
Pollock considerately so they do as
you've stopped the interest of the
junction and a bit further back there's
a tarmacked area up to the right in
front of a number 22 which is also
usually has a car colony as well
slide which shows no can you go back
which shows the junction on the opposite
side of the road from can you go in
closer where you see those cars park
there is that a private parking area or
is that thank you so that could be
extended it's a public area yeah it's a
public area are there are certain part
of asleep or rather yeah all we have
some of the land there's a footpath that
goes to the above the green area and the
part of its highways and the other side
of the part of the footpath is albeit we
know this because of the reading
frequency of the grass being cut and
they have what different contractors on
the issue as well as around the egress
and ingress onto the site because mr.
jeffris I think if yeah I think you've
answered that question quite concrete
thank you
any further questions no thank you very
much sir that was very clear and concise
thank you thank you right our next
speaker is mr. Bromley
I see you're getting ready for a quick
getaway mr. Bromley you got six minutes
so when once you're ready
let's Thank You German just like to pick
up on the points made by the town
council a tracking diagram has been
submitted it's in the Transport
statement on the question of detail of
design quality of design what I would
ask the officers to do when you're in
discussion or point of clarification is
to zoom right in on one or two of these
units and then you will see the detail
that's been built into the design there
is some quality of design that in this
scheme the collection point is an
interesting one it is sited entirely on
highway land it's where people commonly
place their bins it's only there only
there for a few hours on collection day
they don't need permission to put the
bins out on the highway but the gara
site is currently currently represents
an unattractive an environmentally
degraded site which does not make a
pleasant contribution to the area
development with five dwellings will
result in a reduction in traffic from
the lawful use to the site thirty lockup
garages prior to submitting the
application I presented the proposals to
the Ulster Town Council who I thought at
the time when in principle would
generally favorably disposed towards the
development the Town Council requested
that the big collection point be
accommodated within the site my client
agreed with this request moved the
collection point to within the site
during the course of the application we
have been asked by the planning officer
to amend the position of the beam
collection point moving it away moving
it from within the site to the midway
position alongside the driveway minor
changes have been made with the design
during the course of the application
particularly through the request of the
planning officer
these details were removal of artboards
from the gable ends changing porch
canopy so they had a consistent double
piece style and the removal of a large
central gable in the middle of the
terrace the principal design influence
is to reflect a local character which is
strongly defined by brick terracing with
simple flat frontages we note
third-party comments about
overdevelopment the proposals exceed the
council's recommended separation
distances in development requirements
SPD Part F residential immunity which is
designed to ensure development has a
satisfactory relationship with
neighboring properties in terms of
shading and privacy the private amenity
space for each dwelling exceeds the
minimum garden size is recommended in
Part D of the SPD to two spaces are
proposed for each dwelling which is set
out in the SPD part o there is also a
turning space within the site for
delivery vehicles now compliance with
all of these recommended standards will
ensure the proposals are not an over
development of the site the proposals
are for development of a brownfield site
in a sustainable location within the
confines of a main rural center the
development is well designed and fully
complies with the council's planning
policies the Chairman I ask that the
committee support the offices
recommendation and grant planning
permission Thank You chairman Thank You
mr. Bromley well within the time any
questions for the item please catch the
mr. Bromley you drop you drop your lid
so on this this you can see this where
the bins are going to be left is this I
can see on that sort triangle that's not
private that is highways is it mr.
Bromley we secured the plan from the
Boras account accounts a highway section
that shows all the lambda T that is
maintainable at the public expense so
all of that is within the public highway
thank you okay building parking is there
sufficient parking for visitors or is it
got or have they got to park on the
opposite side of the road
microphone gun please
parking standards support a requires two
parking spaces per dwelling which does
include an element to visitor parking
plus nor point to spaces per dwelling
for I suppose other visitors which means
an extra space this has got ten spaces
for ten dwellings if you include the
north point two per dwelling that should
be 11 spaces but there is available
parking opposite the site in that area
that you looked at earlier question did
you wave at me or you just thank you
guys I'm not going to ask for a German
tour climate change and sustainable
construction you've heard the ward the
the parish council or the town council
member has brought up concerns about not
complying with current best practice in
terms of climate change sustainable
heating system
maximize those opportunities would you
like to explain why didn't why how you
progress these issues and why you think
the town council member is not accurate
in his allegation sustainable features
is location in a sustainable location
rather than in less sustainable
locations which generates traffic which
adds to climate change the compliance
with the very modern and recently
revised building regulation standards
ensures compliance with climate change
for Commons so it's I mean for some
years this Authority did require energy
statements to be submitted then the
building regulations changed and
standards would increase through the
building regulations and that will
ensure the development complies with
modern-day standards any further
questions just to Bromley you're free to
go and they're happy cough gets better
right our next speaker please which is
catch the JUnit member
thank you you've you've heard from a
range of people about some of the issues
here over development inadequate parking
there certainly is inadequate parking
and anything that would encourage
further parking problems in this area
should be considered but I also want to
address one other issue that has not
been raised which is that the design of
site layouts and Road layouts need to
consider the speed and response and
maneuverability size of fire engines and
their ability to access in an emergency
incident ideally by means of in air out
systems or if not them where there
should be fire suppression systems
should contain that they'd be available
to contain a fire because the there are
restrictions on how far how pressure
poses can also go from outside this site
and I am very concerned that not only is
this a problem with over over
development lack of from for gardens
lack of problems with parking spaces
problems with design and the terracing
but there is no has not been thought
been given as to how how a fire engine
can either get in here into the site and
turn around or whether or not other fire
suppression systems could be put in as a
condition if if there are fire
suppression systems conditioned there
also has to be things like home use user
guides and ongoing maintenance has to be
considered so that's over and above what
other people have said about the
problems at parking the problems with
over development and the lack of could
lack of conditions lack of things that
are that are suitable for the SPD on
climate change and whether or not those
conditions have been there met thank you
thank you Jim Jim that's very concise
catch some arrows I can see you're
itching to go in there Camp Lejeune and
was any consultation with the beautiful
parish council members on this
particular stand that there was there
was well actually was sitting in on it
then was consultation with the town
council I just like to ask the previous
speaker was saying that these houses are
sustainable and meet their current
requirements but there's not even
something as simple as solar panels on
the roof and this thing so I think that
it falls down on that and there's no
other provision for any sort of energy
saving or climate change criteria really
from from I'm sure the officers will be
able to comment but from my from my view
the any elements of the SPD have not
been incorporated now the the SPD as a
is gone has been undergoing consultation
hasn't been formally adopted but I would
could ask the officers to say what
weight that has correct on this planning
application yep thank you can see it
over eyes down the points of
clarification Cancer Council Juna do you
comment that the parking is inadequate
and the access for a fire engine which
is clearly critical the critical
importance is inadequate but worse kind
of Council have responded twice on this
on both occasions with no how do in what
areas do you think their responses are
inadequate given that we're told that
the parking issue it does comply with
our own standards
my view is that they have not actually
looked at the conditions on particularly
at weekends I've dealt with a couple of
issues and case problems around this
area where parking has been considerable
problem and you've seen that the state
of the Verge's but it's not only the
state of the Verge's this one well I
can't say but there is a cave the case
not very far away from here which is
presented me with really blind I think
that's correct and I noticed on the in
answer to the whether or not the
highways people had been into it I'm not
sure whether the fire authority has been
concerned well again we'll raise that on
points of clarification starts at that
point pretty much you're free to go two
points of clarification I think we've
got several but who can say else did you
indicate thank you very much so there's
been put forward about the design and
the height are the height of the
buildings higher than the rest of the
resident broadly the same I've got a
comparable elevation in my reserves
so every slightly a little taller but
not appreciably so we how much you said
not pleased about my head but I don't
think it was and the other thing one my
concerns when I looked at this was the
is the access to it I know that has been
put to me that the fire engine tips up
you can get quite long hose in there but
is it is such a narrow entrance
are there any measures probably no
measures to have this widened is there
you know from right past the space for
for an ambulance then to pass another
car on that track but there would be no
space for an ambulance to access the
site they had to pass something he
couldn't so in fact two cars couldn't
pass each other is it is that
requirement did you know by highways
that two cars would need to have room
and is there a footpath there as well
the cars meeting it's something we're
faced with with developments and the
county highway authority looked at this
and they've concluded it's acceptable
and what they will look at in that
regard is how often two cars are likely
to meet and I would say and then they
would if it does happen what's the
impact of that and that would be what
happens if someone has to reverse right
back onto the road and of course in this
case visibility is good it's on a bend
the vehicle speeds are low so
in that case what is always at risk the
risk is low enough to be acceptable in
highway terms on on the footpath is it
legally required to prove or pass for a
vehicle to be reversing a footpath for
people to walk on I mean into the soil
yes
no it's not legally required it's its
application for five dwellings and
therefore given the low level of traffic
and the low speeds involved it's
acceptable to have a shared surface if
you were if you were driver it you know
you would be driving slowly anyway need
to have a clear view of any pedestrians
[Music]
unless you've got a speed merchant
thrashing up there is that you speaking
from experience their cancer elves think
we should thank you
right I've got a couple of questions I
think it's one of the conditions anyway
the construction management plan I think
there was an issue raised by mr.
Jeffries about access and blocking the
access and John times of construction
awesome that would be covered by the
construction management plan catch the
Junod raised about the SPD obviously and
it's grown white at the moment and
what's its current weight obviously
we've touched a bit
I think mr. bonnet touch on Part F and
Part D about residents amenities and
spacing and Gardens sighs what's the the
current status of the SPD or the merging
SPD
I think what I think live civil with no
climate change and gone sighs and
potentially spicing yes so with the past
two separation distances garden sized
parking and all of that the SPD has full
weight we've got to climate change
it doesn't enrich a rule explain the
current state of play on the climate
change is policy cs2 is what has full
weight from the core strategy and as
I've advised committee before that has
words such as encourage and promote in
there and that is what we do we
encouraging we promote sustainable
measures within development but we can't
require it the emerging climate change
SPD will have stronger requirements in
it but that is an emerging SPD and at
the moment it's got limited weight
because it's very early in its process
towards adoption what I would say is
it's worth noting firstly of course that
houses will have to be meat building
regs which is separate but nonetheless
provides some level of sustainability
and they would also have electric
vehicle charging points which against
the emerging climate change would be a
ticking the box
beyond that the more general point is is
to say that it's in a main rural center
and therefore by granting a permission
there you are giving people the choice
as to whether they used a car whether
they could walk for short trips to the
local services that are in Ulster so in
that regard and which from a general
point climate change is also looked at
you've touched on one of points about
building regs I won't go on about that
and you have the concern raised by
several people including members in the
committee is the far issue regarding
access for potential fire engine or on
the side and ambulance and pertinency
access prior to get into the site as
well and I don't see any indication of
consultation or
information from the fire authority and
the position with the Fire Rescue
Authority is on significant developments
will consult them and we have a a
memorandum of understanding with them
that this falls someway below so we
wouldn't consult not what's done in that
in my opinion it would be possible for a
fire engine to park close to the site
albeit not right at it and for a host to
extend to where it needed to be because
the distance of the drive isn't
significant thank you right Kevin I know
the SPD has the carrier's limited
weights but it does carry some weight
would you agree with that comment
emerging emerging thank you the part of
that requires cycle storage and this is
in a very built-up area and therefore be
an ideal opportunity for residents to
access the main services in Austin by
cycle by bicycle rather than by car what
provision has been included in the site
for cycle storage there's no explicit
provision within the site for cycle
storage I think that would probably be a
reasonable matter to condition if that
was what you wanted to do yes it's
possible for escape showing the
provision of cycle storage to be
conditioned if you felt that was
important if we then move on to section
v3 improving any energy efficiency in
buildings
what energy efficient the proposals are
included in the design which would
comply with the emitter emerging
document nor accepting it doesn't carry
full weight
I can't answer what exactly would be in
it all I can say is whatever it is in it
would have to comply with the building
regs as they currently stand ie part out
but it does carry some weight and is
very much one of both this this council
this county and and natural government
is going and I think it's disappointing
that we don't see as I think a speaker
said there are no solar panels combined
heating units whatever but it does seem
to rely entirely on independent fossil
fuel heating would that be accurate
conscious that phased out fairly soon
anyway so when you look at the lifetime
of these homes it's likely they're going
to be powered by non-fossil fuels and
there are charging points as part of the
conditioners are conditionally lemony
caramels
can I just look at another slide showing
the terrace houses the plan right okay
that's that's what I need to say things
building their reflux
so although therefore people are can
build up into the roof area there's a
bedroom in the roof there's a bedroom
and an ensuite in the roof in the second
floor as shown here
so is that gonna make it difficult to
put solar panels on if they want so
required no don't think so think they
could be a touch the roof there's still
the sloping roof it would make it harder
but it wouldn't make it impossible if
that was the choice of heat pumps or
corporation of those in the design I'm
just wondering Jessica wonderful to ask
the developers agent the question can
ask the reason why what how ahead Burton
this is you know whether they would be
happy to see a condition whereby some
renewable energy facility is included in
each property ok mr. Bromley would you
like to come forward
I think casick ever has a question I
think he's already indicated what he's
like to ask you about going to ask you
again mr. Bromley you've heard the the
direction my questions personally I find
in terms of design it's very
disappointing that there is no
reflection of where this council is
moving in terms of energy generation
we've got ourselves as confirmed no
ground source heat pumps
we've got no air heat pumps we've got
those solar panels would you be prepared
to accept any conditions that would
introduce some form of renewable energy
into these these schemes but of course
there are the six tests
which the planning manager talked about
earlier this evening does it satisfy the
six Tests it's very much a matter of
judgment is it backed by policy that you
require this is it you have the policy
what is it cs2 looks about sustainable
I'm a change you could probably hang it
on that I don't think solar panels would
be acceptable in design terms they'd
look absolutely awful on this
development front or back an air-source
heat pump is probably the only practical
renewable energy source I think that you
could use on this side so I'm gonna
remain neutral as to whether or not you
consider it reasonable to impose a
condition requiring the submission of a
scheme for renewable energies if you do
if you do impose such a condition I
think the only scheme that my client
would possibly agree to is air source
heat pumps and if my client doesn't like
it of course they can apply to remove it
or appeal against the condition was that
carbon neutral sorry thank you very much
right
thank you catch the cargo that vote of
confidence there right now I think we've
clarified several questions there are
several points on this one there okay
Scott I think in planning terms I've
heard the arguments and I've been driven
around the estate this afternoon
I can clearly see on a Saturday a
parking problem as there are in so many
many estates across Stratford district
however highways have raised no
objection and the layout does comply or
not the layout that the quantity
supplied does comply
our own design standards and whilst I
have every sympathy with cancer Cargill
and the resident Junaid I don't think
there is a policy reason in terms of
highways while we can object it to this
application and similarly again with the
fire service they're not a consulting
but I very much hope that highways would
be considering access for the emergency
services when putting a scheme of this
type together they are the experts on
highway matters so I think sympathy with
the proposal but not I don't think it is
so I think we if it if it went appealing
we would just get both straight over if
we use that for any reason for objecting
to this application
I do have far more sympathy with
environmental issues that were raised
and therefore I think I very much like
to go down the proposal that if we were
to support this application that source
heat pumps were included in each
property we I think as councillor
poundin and the portfolio holder said in
July this year we are facing a sea
change and we have to recognize under
mr. Blondi's helpfully said under CS 2
we might be able to hang it I very much
hope officers will be able to use cs2 as
a peg on which to put it on I there are
an awful lot of solar panels all over
this district and yes they're pretty
unattractive in many situations I don't
have any less unattractive in this and
on these properties than they would bear
anywhere else but give them up what I
felt was a slight resistance for mr.
Bromley I would be inclined to go down
the middle route and say I would support
application if we had a condition that
said grand air source heat pumps were
included in it in terms of design
having looked around the restive state
is what for my close respect 1950s build
of lines of not long long times of
terraces but they're there their blocks
of terraces and I actually find the the
design of this site more attractive than
we had in the past except I hate so my I
would support this application if we
were prepared to put a condition on I
would object to this on the basis of
over development this seems to be in
planners Minds now that's squeezing in
so much we will end up we won't be able
to breathe there's no room for expansion
of anything if people have children
it just seems way over development that
would be my objection to policies so I
think we have to be careful what
language we use and say I think plan is
to make a judgment based on the policies
and our merging SPD's and notice the
partition party and the residential
immunity regardless faces a minimum
garden size the standards were met so I
think have to be careful on that the
only other thing I would mention before
if we've gone further we did mention
cycle storage
so that would be another one and the
other thing I would be concerned about
again as part of construction management
plan condition number seven is
safeguarding access especially during
construction that mr. Jeffries mentioned
daily so that's some of the things again
we need to have in the round when we go
through the proposals or what about
cancer fielding construction management
plans with clear iron she does not want
it so she wants bigger estates bigger
developers to have construction event
management plans reference was made to
construction management plan we've got
to have a means of getting the traffic
officer John
sarcastically obviously we've not got an
independent confirmation from the from
the officer but I think it's unfair to
quote the officer when we haven't got
thank you I feel that we've got a you
can't have or we need a construction
management plan in place if that is
allowed because we've got to get make
sure none of the contractors vehicles
are going to be on that corner it's a
dangerous corner so we've got to make
sure that that is the case condition
seven
the levy space to get the vehicles off
the road
fair enough
thanks mr. chairman yeah thanks Mitch oh
do I like it no it does look a bit
crammed in doesn't it but um it just fit
in with our policy because they've got
plenty of room the access looks pretty
poor to me but within highways sorry
council highway just said there's not a
problem I looked pretty awful but I
can't think of a good reason why I could
refuse his applications chairman so
thank you yeah I was just going to
invite councillor Henshaw Seraphin you
discounted his comment what I was going
to ask him is and policy we're in the
policy and the core strategy would you
I'm happy to support you on that basis
but well where which policy would you
would you turn around and say it's not
it's non-compliant because the core
strategy in terms of I didn't say
there's nothing compliance I would base
my thoughts and common sense we are
squeezing anymore it's just over
development in my mind I would say
probably three houses in there at the
most not not five
what my concern is that that we have got
a policy that's been agreed regarding
residential amenities spacing minimum
garden size and we have to go by our
policies and I'm concerned that if we do
refuse this application the number of
houses and though the development and
squeeze in that sector
pumpkins are very concerned that this
would go to appeal and I'm not sure what
the outcome would be but I've got a good
idea so it will be nice see perhaps -
and - but that's not how it is isn't it
the biggest thing for me and I've
already mentioned it anyway but there
isn't a nod at all in any direction of
climate change or facilities on these
buildings
so that conforms to the emerge and
though it's an emerging policy and it
only carries a certain amount of weight
but it's it's just a complete disregard
in my opinion for for climate change
adaptability for the Heritage that's all
again I think we are limited what we
couldn't do I think one with the change
in the building regulations that mr.
Gardner mentioned area there has been
some improvements compared to what we
were able to do before we've got the
condition the home the EB charging
points with cap circuit law was proposed
sort of with tacit approval from mr.
Bromley but even my niche also I'll
remember that phrase and they can
central condition for earth air source
heat pumps I'll get it all right so that
there is more of concession there's more
of a more of a change in this report and
that was originally proposed and I think
we'll very limited what we can do so we
have seen some change or potential
prepare
and with the psychical storage as well
again we're trying to encourage
sustainable transport what is that and
again and that's one of the other
conditions isn't it as sustainable
Chancellor trying to get people off the
roads and not using the cars so with the
potential historical storage that again
is one plank in the armory
to get to improve the climate change
okay so and just hoping what's comes
back and then I'll come back right if we
talk about climate change there doesn't
appear to be enough garden to plant a
dream now surely whatever we do these
days we should plant a tree for climate
change there's no requirement for space
to plant tree there's a requirement of
minimum garden sizes and they are met in
this instance in terms of policy there
is no requirement just come can I just
come back in on that one of the yeah I
agree with the sentiment about planting
trees and I know that one should attempt
to count so it's got a policy as part of
their budget to plant trees I'm sure
we've got one as part of our budget to
plant trees lots of partners towns and
parish councils I've got them and theirs
as well and there will be work between
the districts that the county the price
is and individual organisations to plant
as many trees as possible and I think
whilst an extra five on this site would
be good I think with the hundreds of
thousands of trees that the local
authorities a lot used to be planting
they were significantly way block of
firewood got here and again the
residents themselves my about to come up
in their own then their own green ideas
as well a quick point to say that
condition for has recommended is hard
and soft landscaping and there's
evidently room for some tree planting in
the
and currently the site has no trees at
all so that would be new trees planted
albeit not in degree gardens a level of
trees if that gives you some comfort on
that point but as Sara said there's no
policy requirement that a cycle store is
conditioned and heat pumps are
conditioned as additionally the existing
conditions and council Fielding's
construction management plan which is in
any way
tree planting outside the gardens which
we've assumed here appears to be I'm
sorry I probably should have asked this
at the the planning offices the the the
green bins you know the household
they'll have to trundle through their
houses when they do the green bins
outside there depends if I go into the
green bin ski probably website not green
bins I'm so sorry any bin then any bin
there has to be will it be have to come
through that out so clarify and you can
see plot one here would access by this
side entry that's one here as well which
has a shirt looks like has a shared
access
up here Steve is that so wouldn't have
to put any pins in the front then no
pins of any color I'm really I'm happily
at second for that proposal well it
could have been listening cats there
William the proposal is to accept the
accept youonce recommendation with the
with the additional conditions there is
a cycle store provided for each property
or common-law cycle adequate for all
properties and that source heat pumps
are provided for each property as well
and the construction management plan
would particularly safeguard access as
part of the part of it it's part of
construction management plan and weights
most practical and reasonable to do so
so we've had a proposal have we a second
different up mm second chance the
fielding
the took extra conditions that have been
recommended the cycle storage there is a
level of support in the SPD you for that
so that back to my mind is a condition
that would meet the six tests the air
source heat pump is a little bit more
difficult for the reasons are given
that's because the policy that would
require it has only got limited weight
at the moment so my advice would be that
that wouldn't be the six tests because
there's no policy underpinning that
particularly the girl to the measures
already in place that meets yes to the
adopted policy thank you for that guard
another if we go to cs2 and I'm just
trying to find it
mister Romney did say he's going to
remain neutral on it but he did hint
that cs2 might be the right home before
it could we just re tech on that to see
if there's anywhere that we could do
because I have to remind you this
counsel unit well nobody voted against
it there was well understand the
distinction but thirty five members of
this council supported the climate
change initiative and we have
subsequently seen the SPD which because
it doesn't carry for weight it doesn't
carry no weight and you confirm that
early wrong it carries some weight and I
think we should recognize that and seek
on that basis to include it if mr.
Bromley wishes to appeal it then he or
his client does and so be it
he may wish to seek to vary that at a
subsequent stage but that is something
that's up to him to decide I think we
should set the standard on this and seek
to ensure that these properties seek to
maximize the benefits of the climate
change initiative the web serie
obviously all conditions have to have
policy reasons the policy reason behind
that would be be emerging SPD
underpinned by cs2 as well and I'm just
trying to get two CS to anicon cs2
and encourages its the requirement comes
from the emerging SPD but promotion and
encouragement is something that we
should be doing by requesting our source
okay so the policy requirement is that
ucs-2 and and reinforced by the early
emerging SPD okay thank you right so
we've I think we should do something
about that now we've had a proposal to
grant the application second year to
podcast the fielding those ticklish
subject to the two conditions for the
amendment of the management and yeah an
amendment to the construction management
plan so all those in favor and to
committee resolves to grant application
1902 77 0 fu L
swiftly um right well our next item on
the agenda is 1902 7 through some very
Chappell view London Road ships
announced our variation of congestion
six of outline permission in the
burton's /ot 3602 my occupation of
twenty Driving's utilizing the temporary
vehicle of a vehicle access good today
right completion of the permanent access
to the site an associate ghost island
Junction
Thank You chairman the sights shown here
realizing the southern part of ships
turn on scour and its opposite the
cemetery on London Road
so outline planning permission was
granted for fifty-five dwellings on this
site back in 2016 and construction is
well underway I understand that they
were around thirty percent of the
dwellings that have been constructed and
of that 55 in total thirty five percent
would be affordable homes comprising
fifteen social rent and for shared
ownership properties nineteen in total
so any plan that outline permission was
granted at Appeal there was a condition
condition six that required a ghost
island and an access to be provided
prior to occupation of any of the
dwellings there are separate agreements
that need to be secured under the
Highways act separate to planning
permissions and work is progressing on
those agreements the access that's in
situate the moment is a temporary access
and it's subject to a section 184
agreement and permanent works will be
later carried out so at the moment we
have a situation we have a
Commission on the site 455 dwellings
they can't be occupied until the
permanent highways works can be
installed that agreement has not yet
been completed but work is progressing
on that so the applicant is seeking to
occupy up to 20 of the dwellings they've
been shown shaded in blue on the plan
utilizing the existing temporary access
so ahead of the permanent permanent
access and the ghost island which allows
for a right-hand turn into the site from
London Road and pedestrian access
pedestrian crossing as well it also
includes some footpath realignment to
allow for the widening of the carriage
way to get that Ghost Island in so this
picture here shows the existing access
this is as it is currently so where you
see the line down the center of the
London Road that as approved or the
permanent consent has been sought by
highways would include a ghost island so
that's a hatched area down the middle of
the carriageway which would allow
vehicles turning right into chapel view
to not obstruct the traffic flow on the
London Road this is the view north so
that's so looking out of the site
looking north so there would be
alterations here to the footpath
alignment on the chapel view side of
London Road and the view south similarly
and you'll see the line down the center
of the road that would all change under
the permanent highway approvals that are
being sought to allow this a right-hand
turn there so good progress is being
made to the section 2 7 8 agreement for
permanent highways works and to
understand that the delivery period of
eight months is necessary to allow for
the completion of the legal agreement
under the
my ways act includes tender process who
roads based licenses and time for the
actor works to be undertaken subject to
planning permission being granted so up
to 23 Elling shown within that area
shaded blue would be occupied prior to
the provision of the ghost island and
the other access works seven of those
are affordable
so three are shared ownership homes on
which contracts have been exchanged and
there are families waiting to move in
and four of which our social rent unit
so this proposal amending that condition
to allow occupation of up to twenty
dwellings utilizing this access would
provide for would also allow for
eighteen dwellings have electric vehicle
charging points now the permission
granted on appeal didn't include any
electric vehicle charge
because it predated our SPD on air
quality so this is seen as a significant
environmental enhancement on the
original scheme so in conclusion there
would be no harm arising to highways
matters there is no change proposed to
the internal layout that has been
approved and also a condition relating
to fire hydrants so fire access and
other provisions for fire services would
also be transposed to any variation and
I've suggested that in the list of
conditions also the scheme would offer
two significant social and environmental
benefits firstly the immediate delivery
and occupation of seven affordable units
some of which contracts have been signed
and families are waiting to move in and
also the provision of eighteen units
with environment electric vehicle charge
in the locations shown on this plan
which the original outlined planning
permission didn't secure so the officer
recommendation is to approve subjective
conditions
transposed from the original outline
planning permission and also a section
106 to ensure that the affordable
housing that's been secured together
with contributions are secured on any
very
that we may agree and that any approval
would contribute constitute a wholly new
planning permission hence the need for
an amend and a deed of variation to the
section 106 thank you right on to our
first speaker which is mr. John Denny
place again apologies for keeping you so
long
apologies for keeping you so late so
sorry about that
first of all we're intending to be here
to represent themselves unfortunately
they've been prevented from doing so I
can assure you that my views are
entirely in line with this yes so first
of all let's - clip I weren't prevented
they didn't register in Tom to speak
though we have clear procedures and they
weren't prevented from speaking their
own presented because they didn't follow
our procedures so I'm not having that
statement and secondly you are here as a
resident you are a town counts that but
these are law views is a resident is a
local resident but you are saying they
mirror the town councils is but again so
can we start again
fresh start like right far away orbit
and the council highways department have
had for years to agree upon and
implement a safe Junction at the
entrance to this site they have failed
they are currently in bridge of
condition six and condition 14 because
they have moved people onto the
cite the Appeal decision put in place
condition six and condition 14 to ensure
that it would be safe condition six for
the road layout and condition 14 for the
street lighting in July 2018 or button
works you can't cancel highways put in
place an agreement to agree and gave
themselves six months they failed again
in the same agreement there's also a
commitment to undertake a road safety
audit which they also failed to complete
for the whole of 2019 orbits and works
at ninety canceled highways have been
first ignoring and then trying to find a
way around the problem they have still
not technically approved a road layout
or a lighting scheme the root cause of
the lack of safety is the speed of
traffic approaching the crest of the
hill before the junction especially in
the dark and your photographs showed
that the traffic entering the 30 mile an
hour zone is frequently traveling much
faster our local speed monitoring group
have recorded speeds up to and exceeding
60 miles an hour southbound traffic on
the London Road also speeds up and can
be traveling well over 30 miles an hour
at the crest of the hill there is no
attempt to make this better granting
this planning application will encourage
these behaviors to continue orbit and
work certainty Council should not gain
from their repeated failure measures
which could be taken are reducing the
speed limit further south with early
warning countdown markers like long
Compton and a 40 mile limit before the
30 mile limit traffic calming to slow
down the speed of the traffic
at the Gateway point creatively using
the width of London Road to provide
cycleways would also would also slow the
traffic in the area a mini roundabout or
traffic lights at the junction is a
possibility in any event temporary
traffic lights should be installed until
the permanent solution is delivered this
planning committee should instruct both
orbit and work for County Council
highways to examine their own internal
project management processes to prevent
future similar failures right student in
place any questions
yeah you mentioned the the independent
speeding group traffic watch is that a
required speed watch group yes obviously
with us and forget to calibrate yeah yes
and you're saying that from there in one
cases potentially 60 mile an hour and
you're the case going out and over the
30 mile we have one recording of 77
miles an hour but okay that's the
exception and was the other point and
you're saying about the lighting there
was something about one point I couldn't
quote if you pull up the plan I can show
you that proposed new lighting columns
which are not in place
[Music]
so temporary exit was intended for
construction use during daylight yeah no
which is thank you very much that's yeah
I was very clear
thank you any further questions no thank
you very much so you're free to go
thank you could you turn the mic off
please thank you
right it's no further speakers
we'll go on two points of clarification
cast cutter can I just confirm looking
at the card councils authorities letter
of the 12th of February are they saying
that it's either the 20th occupation the
ghost on has to make of these before the
20th is what they're requesting or
within eight months so if they get to 19
or 18 and we're a year away they will be
caught by the seconded conditional eight
months
so the initial comments from so these
were the comments from County highways
on the amended plan but once the no
right hand turn Sian temporary signage
was removed so the comments in the
committee report refer to delivery of
the junction arrangements prior to
occupation of the 20th dwelling and
within eight months of the date of any
permission I went back to seek
clarification on that because orbit
homes the applicant is seeking talks by
twenty so really it would need to allow
her occupation delivery of the junction
prior to occupation of the 21st that
dwelling that would be the trigger so in
the suggested conditions condition
condition to the suggested wording is
prior to the occupation of the
twenty-first Welling and within a period
of no longer than eight months from the
date of this permission that the access
to the site and the ghost island
Junction shall be positioned and laid
out yeah so there is there are two tests
one the 20th and the second is twenty
yes that's correct the eight-month
period arose due to the time that's
required for once any section two seven
eight agreement is completed there needs
to be a tender process there's other
requirements for road closures or other
potential things that that are included
and then to actually deliver the
permanent access Arrangements can take
up to eight months I understand sorry I
can't get my head round not be mentioned
this this right hand turn it's not muddy
in the water anywhere there's not
condition or anything is it but it's
gotta put in the original permission on
on the outline
planning permission it was allowed on a
period so the wording of the condition
may not be similar to wording we might
use now several years ago so condition
six that were the applicants are seeking
to amend reads prior to the first
occupation the access to the site and
associated ghost island junction shall
be positioned and laid out in general
accordance with details shown on an
approved plan number which they've
overlaid in in their submission so the
ghost island is not a physical island
where there's a stepped curb or
somewhere to wait it's the hatched area
down the middle of the highway and to
enable that the rope it needs to be
widened the roadway so there'd be
alterations to the footpath on the
development side of London Road and that
would allow for vehicles coming in to
ships than traveling north to wait in
the middle of the carriageway and to
turn right without traffic stopping
behind them sorry I'm I'm getting
confused to kind in here then this going
out of the asite where was this as
Jessen of a no right turn that's a rose
when the application first came in i
consulted county highway that's now gone
County highways said no work but not
happy with that it wouldn't be
enforceable and it would create
potentially more traffic hazards yeah
thank you started semantics 20 or 21 in
the application for the under paragraph
five or section 5 it says Frances
Trenchard occupation in the application
form so while we're using 21 that was
amended the description of the proposal
and highways were made aware of that I
can't remember the exact stage but I did
look back to see where that change had
happened so the original application
referred to as you say the 20 dwellings
but the applicant is seeking through
through the application to allow
patien of 20 prior to the permanent
access works so that the the description
of the proposal was publicized in
accordance with what's now being sought
which is the occupation of 20 dwellings
I'm not sure that we can do anything
with in planning but there's
considerable concerns have been raised
about raised about safety on the road is
there any way in which we can raise
those concerns you know that just what
just seeking advice really on what we
can do about those County highways when
they amended their stance so no
objection to the proposal I understand
there are ongoing discussions and
they're progressing very well with orbit
between the technical teams the
engineers that deal with the highways
agreements and it relates to street
clutter and other things another signage
so they are looking at enhancing the
environment really around that access so
their ongoing talks about outside the
remit of planning really but I
understand there is ongoing engagement a
bit between the parties can we just pick
up the item on the street lighting issue
is it a condition that the street
lighting is in place and have if it is
if it is a condition and there is no
street lighting well what is happening
where are we in that issue because much
of a major concern to the gentleman who
spoke earlier on rightly so I'd agree
the original outline permission did have
a condition on condition 14 which I
think counselor duly referred to and it
did require details of all external
street fittings and street lighting
columns to be submitted to us for
approval now we have approved those all
of the conditions have had sign-off
they've all been discharged so if we
minded to approve the application we
would transpose the conditions as they
have been discharged to call
however the condition drafted and the
condition on the outline approval
doesn't actually give a trigger for when
for when the street lighting has to be
physically installed and operational
on-site so there is opportunity in this
application to provide some indication
and trigger to allow for street lighting
to be provided and I have a plan on the
later plan that it does show the the
existing columns there are two there are
two on the site just in the access I
think on one on the right hand side one
on the left hand side one on the right
they're existing they are in place and
orbit homes have indicated that another
additional three or four I believe in
the area that would be occupied
utilizing the temporary access would be
provided by April 2020 so it's a
weakened condition accordingly if the
street lighting isn't necessary are you
looking at the one with the design with
the photographs the plan with the
photographs included the gentleman used
I have got that plan I have it's a blue
plan that it was the earlier plan that
showed the area within which twenty
dwellings could be occupied they're the
ones that are indicated and I've had a
later plan further into discussion with
the applicants this afternoon just
asking them to clarify where the
existing lighting columns are there are
two on the site and three or four
additional proposed and they would be
installed for April 2020 so if necessary
we could condition accordingly
we continue we'll carry on until all the
Indus application yep
I think I'm done electrification it's a
clarification I'll just bear with me
while we've sort out this technical
hitch
boss boss will wait in Casterly Rock
well have a slighter German on this
application and then we'll come back in
no so we've got this lighter German and
we'll come back in there and we've gone
past the three hours of the committee so
I'm proposing that we carry on what's
over here so I need formal approval or a
second different cancer kettle that we
carry on past the the three hours right
never mind make some savings
these days but on the actual debate that
we've gone through the points of
clarification but so I think we've
clarified all the points we need you to
look at one point you've identified on
the map a number of properties will have
electric charging points but not all now
given were debating a condition to
extend its twenty you know their word
twentieth occupation why can we not have
electric charge points in all the
properties well the the legislation the
section 73 allows us to very conditioned
on a planning permission and it does if
approved result in a permission that
stands alone is so right but we can't
rewrite the whole planning application
or reconsider everything so in this case
for example the electric vehicle
charging points there are a number of
properties that have been constructed to
require the applicant to retrofit
electric vehicle charging points would
be unreasonable hence we've sought the
most that we can and they are on the
majority at the part of the site that
hasn't yet been built out so there are
18 to our legs on the eastern part of
the site today I'm happy with this are
not happy the way with the issues at
home highways seem that the delay the
second place but that can't form part
our debate on this application it's not
a planning matter whether we have the
ability to respond and it refers our
concerns to highways I would like to
suggest our Chairman should investigate
that but what I would suggest is that we
approves the application but with the
condition that the officer
suggested that we bring in the lighting
column issue and make that a a condition
of this application so the concerns of
jedicon raised are addressed we are
moving in the summer so to become less
relevant after April May but I think
it's a great opportunity to get those
lighting columns in than that I'd like
the condition to be included and I rose
on that basis that we accept the
recommendation with the amended
condition or with the included
additional condition I think we do need
to find out what good is what issue was
between the County Council and the
applicant which is in this case all of
it so it's - what the issues were and
what lessons can be learned because
obviously this is not acceptable as mr.
Denis said no I totally agree so I think
we knew we do need to find out and I
will get a response back is generally
the committee thank you right kosuna did
you indicate it's just to back up the
idea that though it's not a planning
issue we would like to have the concern
our concerns raised about safety with
the relevant authorities yep catch them
else exactly the same thing I meant mr.
Denny spoke very passionately about this
and it does seem the highway he's been
very tardy with this so yeah do I gather
from what's been said that there are
people already living in the in the
houses yeah but and therefore we've got
to just when we put temporary traffic
lights up or get them to put some sort
of traffic temporary traffic lights is
that possible
miss Jim the street lighting condition
has been mentioned
that's condition 10 has recommended
obviously with that remembers one look
at the detail of that that could be
recommended to be that that is provided
within three months of the permission
would be my suggestion and within it
within the area of the occupations that
are going to take place ie the 20
occupations that are allowed prior to
the final completion of the access so
that that would be my suggestion if
members are comfortable with that you're
not allowed to come back up without um
if members of the committee want to ask
you a question for clarification
regarding your comments you can come
back up when we can ask you but
unfortunately if laid out we can't ask
you to come back up so if there's any I
need clarification to mr. Denny regard
the lighting well I will ask question
who the officer or the off-site why you
proposing here to layer three months I
mean hopefully by now the
infrastructures in place and therefore
this is a highway safety issue and there
are two parties here orbit and the
County Council and they can't know
whichever party it is I think the higher
safety is critical highways are happy
with it but I think I just wonder why
you say three months mr. Garber I say
three months because it's an engineering
operation it would take time it's within
your gift to go for a lower period but
obviously the lower you go the less
reasonable little more only because
as a condition so that's why I started
with three months it's not for me to
propose I think it's a suggestion so
that you're fully aware of the facts and
any decision you make I think to some
the other point is well I think it was
two points it wasn't it was a street
light and it was condition I think six
six and 14 on the previous application
approval one was to do the roads I think
number six and the 14 was to do with the
streetlights yep you just come forward
and clarify those two points so I mean
then the student that comes to the it's
just those two points on number six on
the roads and number fourteen on the
street lights that as part of the
approval previous approval those two
areas should have been done that's what
I think that was one variety to the
loads and one related to street lighting
can you just clarify my understanding
this correct and what the issue was on
number forty in the street lighting
right the important thing is to get the
lighting on the main road the lighting
beside the houses is I believe that in
your judgment but the lighting on the
main road is the important point so the
travelers on the main road can see the
junction and the other thing is the
gentleman who suggested temporary
traffic lights yes please okay okay
second point you should listen it but
we've got that point up so thank you for
that Rockette smells and then cancer I'm
sorry miss Jimmy is come baking the
safety thing I think we go every
emphasizes my sat in the in the car had
some question to mr. de Aziza pressure
back to the offices not to mr. dinner
rot
you're free to go back now sir right I
think we've got as much as we can from
you is legally possible as you can
so I emphasize is safety and if I sat in
in the car in the entrance to this site
looking out and they did come thundering
over the area I mean they are talking
from so just John suggested traffic
light will be good all right let's go
back to the lights first so the concerns
are lighting on the highway and the
light in actually on the development
potentially road safety and traffic
issues so I think we do need
clarification on those ASAP one from the
offices in to from from the highways I
think after firstly the the red line up
of the application site doesn't include
the area on the highway where I
understand that mr. Dooley is suggesting
the street lighting should be the plan
that I've been provided with in the
overlay plan here does show the existing
lighting columns on the London Road and
also some one the entrance but they
would be subject to the section two
seven eight agreement details they're
not something that was required on the
original outline permission when that
was allowed it just required details of
lighting columns exactly to be provided
they have been provided and agreed by us
however we're in a position if this
application for example hadn't been
submitted or isn't taken forward there's
no trigger as it stands for any street
lighting to be provided in terms of
planning and enforcing that because
although the details of
right it there's no trigger in the
condition as it's currently worded to
require that to be implemented at a
certain stage of the development so the
suggested condition we would be looking
at to transpose the condition the light
street lighting on to any variation and
impose that there should be some trigger
in that respect but that wouldn't relate
to the lighting on the main London Road
without the outside of the site so we're
doing a supplementary agreement to bring
the original six one eight six agreement
so this is section 73 permission and
again is there any reason I'm sure
Richard or myself tell me I won't be
able to do it
his only reason we couldn't augment that
supplement to improve the lighting I'm
trying basically doing is basically
transferring the obligations or making
sure that the obligations fit with the
original agreement or any supplemental
so basically they are obligated by the
obligation to whichever permission they
choose just to come back on the planning
point around the the off-site lighting
the comments are made earlier about the
on-site lighting the whole purpose of
this application is that what they are
requesting is to occupy twenty dwellings
with access Arrangements as they are so
as you see it on-site today with
whatever lighting arrangements are in
existence at the moment once they hit
the 21st dwelling they need to have
upgraded that access which would include
any upgraded street lighting but to
require them to do some street lighting
now it's what I mean they're under a
load of Section two seven eight works
and you're effectively taking the
permission away if you granted it with
that condition okay thank you for
I'm completely muddled now SCADA because
you said that Iran and I questioned
whether three months was too long you
said that you could bring in a condition
which had a requirement in three months
as I said that was referring to the
streetlights within the site is talking
about those in the current highway so I
say we cannot condition highway
streetlights to address the concerns
raised by the resident I think it would
be unreasonable because in effect it
would mean they couldn't occupy until
they'd sorted that out so they'd have to
get the scheme proved they'd have to
then deal the engineer works to do it
and they'd be they'd be no further on
they could knock you PI whilst they're
doing that so that's why you're giving
with one hand and taking away with the
other if that condition went on well
it's a 20th occupation or 21st will
although the main road street life thing
have to be in place yes party occupation
whatever approved highway works are the
ghosts turning lane that they're asking
and any street lighting that highway see
fit under Section 2 7 8 to like that
that would all have to be in place it
just seems 8 months is not a long way
from today it takes us practically
through into what November when the
evenings or the nights are longer than
the days and we still won't have a
potentially we won't have a full
lighting scheme in so where where is the
8 you know can we vary the 8 months
well the advice of our highway officers
is that it is acceptable for the
existing situation to carry on and to
have 20 dwellings occupied once they hit
21
have to have the new scheme in place
whilst I understand the all the planning
and a legalities this comes under please
refer to the County Council that we are
not very happy with this Cathleen of
this kind of because it is a safety
issue
now we can't require them but we're not
happy getting the feeling you were
ignoring me no more than usual getting
late traffic lights which I suggested
three-way traffic lights until such time
as the traffic calming and other matters
are sorted out for safety reasons along
that road would that be possible
as I say the Highway Authority looked at
this and it would have been within their
gift to recommend that they haven't done
so so any condition that you've put on
to require that would duplicate highway
powers that have already been looked at
to decide whether 3-way traffic lights
are needed so it's possible but in my
view it wouldn't be lawful go back to
them and ask again bearing in mind that
the feeling of this committee I think
it's yes you could do if that was the
feeling of the committee but it would
require a deferral to go back to County
to raise the issue
and they again they compute energy put
on so the lights wouldn't be there again
if we couldn't in the construction
method statement number 18 if they could
produce something that maximizes Road
Safety so the point that the officer
made that we do have the opportunity to
introduce a condition in relating to
highways what could you just come back
to me on what that that point you're
making was the application seek in two
very condition six so we would be
looking to reword that condition to
allow occupancy of up to twenty
dwellings before the permanent access
arrangements and whether there are any
other conditions we've been through all
of the conditions on the outline
permission they've all been discharged
where the change to condition six may be
impacts on other conditions that will be
covered but there is the scope under the
legislation to impose other conditions
but they have to be there to meet all of
the conditions tests and we can't
rewrite a permission again we can't do
so you've proposed I'm very unhappy with
with the highways approach and I you've
made that comment that you'll take that
up we've been told we can't amend we can
but we can't amend their conditions
materially I always have requested
traffic lights so I understand John's
concern I take on board fully the
residents comments but what were being
told is that we have very little
opportunity to display that so I think
we just have to go with the author's
recommendation dose 13 so proposal a
second and we rewrite to find out what
the issue is
regarding the applicant and the highways
and oh this can we prevent it from
happening
yep Chris so proposed and second that
grant application with you know to
condition us and Viet note that we right
to orbit and the Canada Council to
explain and express our displeasure and
want to know what the problems are
what's taking so long and have it can be
it wouldn't be known the permission I
can undertake as planning manager to
write on committees behalf I'm looking
at may say on committees behalf to raise
concerns over the length of time that
the section two seven eight agreement
has taken but it's nothing that's not
for the applicant this authority to
approach County Council's say we feel
that section two seven eight process is
been too slow in this case yeah and I
think yeah the emphasize the road safety
issues yeah and you know with busy the
County Council is trying to improve road
safety and that this committee felt that
that delay has resulted in an ongoing
situation Highway Safety was was not
what it could be and yet potentially
right okay talk about them all those in
favor
committee resolves to grant publication
19 / 0 2 7 3 7 very final item on the
agenda is non d /o 2 8 5 once the city
well did more poor her brain this is for
regular access harvest time and front
boundary war bears and gates the
retrospective application
just wanted the miser
[Applause]
if it was in to six Thank You chairman
Vionnet will be presenting this also
over to fairness Arabella some sites
here dim whirlpool had lain the site's
located within the West Midlands green
belt and the Arden special landscape
area it's been the subject of planning
permission for a replacement dwelling
originally approved in 2016 and revised
in 2019 the area's wholly residential
features large detached dwellings for
deep frontages and a range of front
boundary treatments slides here show the
boundary treatment that has been
approved and the further slide show
proposed or talk back to these in a
minute so the house is built and this
application relates solely to the front
boundary treatment so the dwarf
long-wave brick piers stone cappings and
the gates so retrospective planning
permission was sought for six additional
brick piers so you see as approved there
the spacing between the brick piers was
much wider from that which is now
proposed and has been constructed so 13
in total with a height of between one
point nine meters thirteen point two
meters the piers adjacent to the gates
being the highest they proved piers have
a height of nine point nine meters the
dwarf floor one has a height of more
point five to nine point seven meters
compared to that of nine point four or
five meters as approved the dwarf Holden
piers have been constructed and the
height of the piers would be reduced
from two point three meters as
constructed who's a picture here so two
point three meters at present and the
application seeks height between one
point nine to two point two
a type of boundary treatment this type
of boundary treatment features heavily
in the streets while there are some
properties that have open frontages and
deep Gardens the majority have some form
of them closer to the front including
railings dwarf brick walls brick piers
and all heading and shrubs this is a
property of percent so you can see a
very similar arrangement with the
lower-level shrub planting up to the top
of the wall this is a property Allerton
we're planting has been established in
front of the boundary wall and railings
and the piers I believe according to the
planning permission and we reported on
ice of 2.1 meters to the underside of
the stone capping these slides show
other examples and the final one is a
street feeling so this is from I think
that looking moves towards the site and
it's outside lodbrok Park Golf Club at
which from this point railings rooms are
all established features well
established within this Street through
our boundary clear enclosures have been
erected so the proposed boundary
treatment with planting as indicated in
the condition albeit slightly increased
in height to that approved would not be
out of character with the variety of
front boundary treatments and would be
less harmful to the open little visual
appearance of the goal note that's
already approved particularly with the
proposed planting to soften some of the
impact of the boundary wall thank you
go to our first speaker save the best of
us catch the broom from Tom with an
ardent Irish capsule and many apologies
for keeping you so long we've had some
quite complex and complicated ones that
we had to debate in detail so so many
apologies so you've got three minutes
that if you like too far away when
you're ready and we'll give you a
warning with 30 seconds to go just press
this button thank you this application
is the seventh application or amendment
submitted to these premises by the same
applicant in three years
none have been either completed or
complied with in refusing the amendment
to 1902 five one our MD for new vehicle
access and boundary treatment submitted
as a result of failure to comply with
the terms of the earlier application the
planning officer wrote these additions
are considered to be material as they
propose a significant increase in the
height of the boundary wall and an
assessment will have to be made
regarding their effect on the openness
of the greenbelt and character of the
area this can only be done by a new
application the new application that we
are considering today offers no
effective change to the overbearing
nature of the boundary as of last Friday
it has 13 pillars of approximately 2.2
meters height and opaque gates of the
same height so continuing the process of
urbanizing pool head lane district
counter at Dickson
has commented it is regrettable that a
rural Lane has over the years lost its
identity and the photographs submitted
by the applicant in the Strait how in
particular the northern part of the Lane
only has over the years being permitted
to take on an urban appearance the
applicant by posting these photographs
is clearly trying to use the principle
of equalization which I believe does not
exist in planning law to substantiate
his plan to further urbanize pull their
plane pour their blame and other leafy
open lanes within the ls visa would end
and tan 'with still retained generally
an open feeling of rural Greenbelt
something that the core strategy and
specifically the tamatha Darden NDP
placed great weight upon contrary to
what is stated in the application the
property does reside within the art and
special landscape area and an essential
characteristic is openness and
permanence 30 seconds sir we still have
an opportunity to stop the relentless
march of urbanization in our community
by insisting that an open aspect is
maintained by the retention of and
planting of hedges and insistence upon
open entrances and or low transparent
gates thank you catch the mouse good
evening seven-thirty they're indicated
they've built the house they haven't no
house has been built the original
bungalow is still the original bungalow
and has gone through a series of
applications
not seven applications for the war as we
can see if you go back to the fifth or
sixth application you will find that the
boundary treatment was a low wall of
equal horizontal across the front
it isn't specified whether it is it is
green or whether it is hard but if you
specified as a low a low wall across the
front of the premises without any
pillars at all judging from what we've
been told it looks it's not a picture of
what's there at the moment is what is
there at the moment that I looked at it
last Friday a property that also had
that similar but the point I'm making is
that if you actually look at the full
length of the lane majority of the lane
is still Liese over the last five to ten
years a number of properties have been
allowed to build what are unacceptable
boundary contain boundaries in leafy
lanes and I believe that we need to call
a halt okay thank you
any other questions
mr coming yes I agree with you that's
quite open in me yes that's quite all
right but open gates as I said yeah but
to build a solid wall through a point is
that it's not slowly but the gates are
solid all the way of doing them off at
the moment but I had seen the gates some
months ago
and they are solid two point two meter
so gate so is she planning to in fill
them with iron railings or so he says
any other questions
okay Safari is the occupant actually
living in the house that's there I
believe so but I I got him thank you
thank you sir
you're free to go thank you
right points of clarification now for
the offices any points of Ken Smith
Pilon what are we talking about a
difference in height of the original
planning application and what does it
look like
as I understand the approved peers have
a height of 1.9 meters 1.9 so we're
looking at proposed between a height of
1.9 to 2.2 meters so they're higher when
they're adjacent to the pier so between
this 300 but on some points it will be
similar so the approved peers have a
height of 1.9 and they're proposing the
height of 1.9 to 2.2 so it won't be a
2.2 across the whole object which is
already isn't it because they built them
at the moment understand that peers the
highest point at 2.3 so they'd have to
reduce very vibrant course
okay stop flowing
gets filled in sorry there is is there
any indication they want to instill it
with metal railings or are we jumping
ahead as their approval the planners
clearly show metal railings between the
brick piers between the gates I'm just
looking at the detail on the plan it's I
think the price council actually stood
up to wooden games yeah it's not
particularly clear so I refer back to
the planning application form which
should do child and materials so says
the walls red brick and metal rails
gates with and gates with stone tops so
I think the gates would judging by this
would be metal welded said red brick and
metal rails are just plates with stone
talks to come back up just to give us
your understanding Suffolk I heard you
mention two wooden gates to something
yep they've been removed but they were
in place they are absolutely solid two
point two meter gates so you have
ingoing and outgoing so across the
breadth of the property you have two you
have wooden gates there and wooden gates
there and they those gates there are
actually solid we can get yeah they can
remove them at the moment
yep thank you
ya know what's this Cass cattle your
proposal is to keep the number of
columns which is currently not in
accordance with the approved plan but
actually bring them back in height down
by 30 centimeters so the height will
then comply with the old approved height
but will still have more will have
additional columns there would be
additional brick columns and the for the
approved height is 1.9 so this does
allow for 2.2 meters in some parts on
the brick piers because they are higher
in some locations and others so a height
between 1.9 to 2.2 depends on the ground
level so ill-conditioned one with the
three months to information them all on
page to be reduced in height and
according to the plans hereby approved
so we're actually going back to the
original plan in terms of height the
plans hereby approved would refer to any
approval that's given on this proposal
so the wording would be if we were to
grant permission for this scheme the
condition would require within three
months on the date of this commission
the wall and peer shall be reduced in
height in accordance with the plans
hereby approved you would be approving
the plans we're looking at now which
show that height reduction so they'd
have to reduce the height from two
points room down to the Heights shown on
the plans which are between 1.9 and 2.2
meters so it's a very insignificant
reduction
I think the key change here I think more
predominantly is the the increase in the
number of brick piers the columns across
the frontage in my opinion
coming to Stowe look at the end of this
industry seeing the gates of the other
properties
so this is opposite so that's the metal
guide looking at that one well she would
just coming on that point by the metal
gate was you were just in discussion
there I do did you may have noticed on
the proposal you'll see that's as
approved the the quality of the
elevations is it's not what it could be
it makes it very hard to see see with
the bungalow looming behind but that's
what's been approved the that's what's
proposed to the gate and my reading of
that the material section of the
application form says it's red brick and
metal rails straight gates with some
tops and I read the metal rail stroke
gates to be that the bottom half of
those gates would be metal and the top
half of them would be railings to match
the railings further along so I'm not
reading that as solid if I I would
suggest that we would need details of
the finish of that metal area there yeah
unconscious it's not recommended but I
would have no problem if members wanted
if they were minded to approve to add a
condition requiring details of that's
just so that we get color
you put your mic on pace chairman and
mr. Gardner approved that a point to say
that it we can get on with the
application whereas at the moment it's
the height to the top of the capping or
is it just to the underside of the
capping for the pillars
I can check that on the plan but I think
I've referred to the height of the wall
opposite to the stone capping I guess
irrespective of that we would be the
height that's being sought is 1.9 to 2.2
meters so with this the brick peer plus
the stone capping that were to be
retained would have to be within that
2.2 meters I'm not sure the plan is that
clear to show whether there's a capping
stone it so 2.2 meters is a bricks and
the cap would drop so we can include
that in the approval if we say okay on
page 52 at the bottom of the greenbelt
paragraph you say it's an inappropriate
formal development would you like to and
then you say it won't cause harm what do
you mean by inappropriate formal
development then if I mean if it if it
doesn't cause me harm it can't be
inappropriate
so in the conclusion I think that rounds
the the point up it highlights that the
proposal is considered to cause harm to
the Greenbelt by by virtue of
inappropriate and its Greenbelt policy
in the core strategy the MPP F
highlights types of development is
considered to be inappropriate so we
have to weigh that in our considerations
however in this case no other harm has
been identified so in accordance with
the Greenbelt policy we have to fully
consider the benefits and justifications
put forward in order to consider
consider whether these constitute very
special circumstances which outweigh the
harm to the Greenbelt so in this case
the conclusion of the officer is that in
this case although the current proposal
increases the number of peers and also
the height of the peers in the dwarf all
it does include planting to the front of
the wall to provide some screening which
would make the proposal less harmful to
the openness and the visual appearance
on the Greenbelt compared to that
already approved so it would be an
enhancement overall in terms of the
Greenbelt council most thanks I'm sorry
mr. chairman getting confused of
counting again so really it goes against
the original application the applicator
increasing the height increasing the
pillars and the original application
yeah that's what we're that's it that's
correct with the additional the plans
show additional planting to the front of
the activator actually move on to the
debate there
I think council Dixon has hit the nail
on the head and it's here but his words
quite clearly this is a rural later I I
drove down it today
I know counts the mills did as well
today
and what struck me is
that all the gardens are generally very
very open except for on this site
because you have the wall on the other
side which does its history is there
presumably it's approved can't do
anything about it
but by building a replica opposite it
you actually create a tunnel in what is
a very open area now if this was in the
same time as this was outside Greenbelt
you probably really wouldn't worry about
it but a greenbelts protected area and
there is considerably greater weight
visual weight to this wall than approved
one and therefore it's only it's a very
small application but it is interesting
that if you go back to the officer's
comment on 1900 673 sorry 2 5 9 o AMD
the officer refused it because it was a
material change and had to be considered
as a separate application now that
officers opinion I respect yours as well
but I respect that
officers opinion and it was a material
change the app can got permission and
then decided to change it without
permission and has put something I said
the impact to me was you've got a very
rural area but very few enclosed Gardens
the one opposite is no one because that
it goes down and therefore in driving
along it's quite easy to look over the
top of the wall but this is on top of a
hill or top of a bank and therefore it
may be any the same height relatively
speaking it's considerably taller and
I'd I just didn't like it's stuck out
like a sore thumb and we have had
planning applications before which were
refused in this committee at some four
weeks ago two weeks ago
we're a proposal was put forward was it
stuck out like a sore thumb
I think when my exact words and that's
exactly what happens here
I like the planting on the front but
there's considerably greater bulk a
unnecessary and if the councillors
comments about the the gates are
accurate and I'm sure I'm not reaching
him that we've got solid gates you
suddenly got a gated entrance a gated
walled entrance that may be very secure
but it is not part of the the old
fashioned word a streak scene of this
particular group which is a very rural
roof with nice non-slip endow with trees
etc and if you look at street scene the
word trees here but quite a lot of them
seem to have been carved up and chopped
up but you've now got a completely open
expanse of water lawn which is
completely separate to every other
property on this street the officer said
it's a material change it is a material
change councillor Dixon has not objected
and minded to go along with the officers
recommendations in fact this is a case
of regional application making me make
me cross I don't like retrospectives but
then I go along the lane and see in my
opinion to rendus properties going up or
actually appalling and then we look at
this they don't this application pales
into insignificance compared with these
other two I know that's not in front of
us at the moment what makes me across
this is a retrospective it's going
against original kinda application why
do it is it
a lot of harm I'm not sure so I'm a bit
torn moment who's chairman I don't like
that they've done this it's it caught in
great deal of harm let me weigh this up
thank you
I think I think it's a balance between
hold on a second please
or something speaking thank you sorry I
think it's it's it's advanced well it's
very special circumstances in the green
bow special landscape area is it
overbearing is it is it an appropriate
and what it cause harm to visional
openness of the green bounce nothing
else that's where the balance is
definitely with the wooden gates if it
was gonna be wooden gates I don't know
what was certainly would be definitely
going against the officers
recommendation but I think we've got to
decide and what it is appropriate
whether again I don't like the
retrospective element but again when you
look at the other ones in that road how
different is it so I think we've got to
decide on that so I'm looking for a
proposal are there to refuse or grant
this so with it do catch the journey did
you indicate that I proposed to grant
with the conditions that the officers
have put have we got a seconder front so
we've had a proposal on a second to
grant application
can't cancel quite correctly Junaid has
pointed out whilst counselor Dixon did
it object in October he would drew the
objection a couple of a couple of weeks
later by requesting that the H is
allowed to grow to two meters not just
to cover the loan wall and their finest
request with that condition that counsel
Dixon has requested which is in response
that we condition the hedges to is two
meters high rather than had to be grown
types two meters that could be summer in
statement of am overall aspect this
warrior name can we can I make that
change the condition what your first of
all you left us came to the Doudna to
see if she accepts that condition I did
to consider that when I visited the site
I noticed that objection but I think
having a two meter high hedge in front
of brick piers and railings would just
look quite obtrusive in the street scene
I wonder in terms of the growth and
establishment of a hedge with that
behind it to that height tell you know
the strength of that head really I can
comment I'm not an expert in that but I
think visually having a two meter high
hedge in front of the walls and railings
as proposed would be more out of
character my I think we did mentioned
earlier about the condition
materials of the gates and whether
you're willing to accept that condition
that it's open gate rather sala de gate
my reading of is mental and therefore
the condition could be to give certainty
and some level of control it would be
unconscious the gates aren't there today
so the condition could be no gate should
be installed unless and until details of
the finishes of the lower part of those
gates has been approved in writing okay
so can surgeon is happy to accept that
so we've had a proposal on a second
with the conditions to grant the
application all those in favor
again to sew committee resolves to grant
application nineteen slash zero two
eight five one a few out thank you we've
got no urgent items business so I'll
close the meeting 1014